please the old white doctor it's only
available after 4:00 it's not your thing
in the whole entire building there isn't
one white doctor has to be some
pediatricians
okay so what you're telling you that my
kid has chest pains he's gonna have to
sit here and cook workup can I see a
doctor
please miss white being white makes him
more good what delicious one pale being
white is different how are you
communicating to everyone clearly has
more issues with you being his mother
than him needing to see a doctor you are
extremely rude and racist you want to
talk about people being at a hospital
maybe you should check yourself there
you are yelling at everyone you're
yelling at everybody so what no we're
not fighting they're fighting because
well there are I'm sure there are other
people who are reasonable she is
perfectly your thing in the whole entire
building there isn't one white doctor
okay what type of horrible time to do
other than somebody else it doesn't have
brown teeth that speaks English
I said well but I I watched him closely
and I noticed that there was it though
they were white and they would call
themself white there was a difference
between them and the white one over here
and that basic difference was this in
the in Asia or the Arab world are in
Africa where the Muslims are if you find
one who says he's fine all he's doing is
using an adjective but to describe
something that's entered incidental
about him one of his instant incidental
characteristics so there's nothing else
to it you just went but when you get the
white man over here in America and he
says he's white he means something else
you can listen to the sound of his voice
when he says what he means he's lost
that's what white means in this language
you know the expression free white and
21 he made it up he said you know love
me the same white means free boss he's
up there so it when he says he's white
he has a little different sound in his
voice and I know you know what I'm
talking about he and this was what I saw
was missing in the Muslim world that
they said they were white it was
incidental white black brown red yellow
as making difference what color you are
and so this was the religion that I had
accepted and had gone there to get a
better knowledge of it
I am NOT a racist in any form whatsoever
I don't believe in any form of racism I
don't believe in any form of
discrimination or segregation
I believe in Islam I know Muslim and
there's nothing wrong with being a being
a Muslim nothing wrong with the religion
of Islam that just teaches us to believe
in Allah as the God and those of you who
are Christians probably believe in the
same God because I think you believe in
the God who created the universe and
that's the one we believe in the one who
created the universe the only difference
being you call him God and we call him
Allah
Jews call him Jehovah if you could
understand Hebrew you'd probably call
him Jehovah too if you can understand
Arabic you probably thought Allah puts
in since the white man your friend took
the only language away from him during
slavery the only language you know is
his language you know your friends
length so you call him you called for
the same guy who calls Paul when he's
putting a rope around your neck you call
for God he calls for God
[Applause]
so that once you realize that what I
believe in the Supreme Being who created
the universe and believe in him as being
one I also have been taught in Islam
that that one God who only has one
religion and that religion is called
Islam and all of the prophets who came
forth taught that religion Abraham Moses
Jesus Mohammed all of it and by the
leaving in one God and one religion and
all of the prophets it creates unity if
there's no room for argument no need for
us to be arguing with each other and
also in that religion of the real
religion of this month when I was in the
Black Muslim movement
I wasn't they didn't have the real
religion of Islam in that movement was
something else and what the real
religion of Islam doesn't teach anyone
to judge another human being by the
color of his skin the yardstick that is
used by the Muslim to measure another
man is not the man's color but the man's
deeds man's conscious behavior the man's
intentions and when you use that as a
standard of measurement or judgment you
never go wrong but when you just judge a
man because of the color of the skin
then you're committing a crime because
that's the worst kind of judgment when
they do start indict us because of our
color that means we're indicted before
we were born which is the worst kind of
crime that can be committed and the the
Muslim religion has eliminated all
tendencies to judge a man according to
the color of his skin but rather the
judgment is based upon his deeds
[Music]